now how do you know the media are scared
of this new trend i'm sure you've seen
it of hispanics moving right well the
new york times sent this la-based
reporter to the rio grande valley
to write a hit piece about the new
republican congresswoman myra flores
saying that she embraces the extreme
while shunning moderates
she's a far-right latina they said about
her so you have to ask yourself what's
so extreme what's the new york times so
upset about
her campaign slogan i suppose because it
was god family country was meant to
appeal to what she calls the traditional
values of her majority hispanic district
in the bordered city of brownsville
well of course it's all sneering right
because
these people pretend to care so much
about the advancement of minorities and
business and education and society of
politics
but unless minorities toe the far left
democrat line what's going to happen
they're going to be smeared just like my
next guest
hear how to respond to the hit piece
texas congresswoman myra flores
congressman great to see you tonight i
think you've officially arrived welcome
to the club people have been smeared by
the new york times got to give you a big
hand how does it feel
honestly i honestly don't really care
about the new york times they know
nothing about me
or my culture like i said we're all
about god family and country
and that's who we are here in south
texas and that's what they call far
right it's it's just insane you know how
they they treat immigrants you know i'm
an immigrant and they claim to be very
supportive of us
but yet when we decide to run for office
and because oh no we are
you know excited and to promote our
values values that they're against right
they're um against the values that we
stand for god and family values so they
hate it they hate it so no i'm you know
i honestly don't really care about the
new york times i'm focused on the
district that i'm running
yeah it's a total badge of honor um so
you i'm sure well you probably were too
busy you were too busy but
socialist alexandre ocasio-cortez was
dubbed
a political star of the future when she
won kind of out of the blue
but you're apparently you're just a
far-right menace what do you say to
latina women across the united states
who are watching this tonight wondering
where they fit in politically and seeing
things kind of turn so negatively in the
economy and so forth uh today what's
your message to them
look all i can say is lc does not
represent the
hispanic community this definitely does
not represent texas district 34 and who
we are here and we're not worried about
you know the washington nonsense latin x
you know worried about the cost of
living gas food you know health care
that's what we're worried every single
day we're not waking up you know and
thinking about you know what's happening
in washington
they're just so disconnected um
it's it's really um it's really sad
because they think that the world
revolves around washington dc and that's
really not the reality
i want to move to something obviously a
lot more important to all of us but
especially to you in the rio grande
valley
texas officials and lawmakers have made
a new call in recent days watch
you hear the term invasion and that's
exactly what this is it is an invasion
that is being pushed by the cartels into
our country and it must come to a stop
recognize an invasion
an invasion of the state of texas that
is undermining our security
risking the health and well-being of
texans
congresswoman do you agree with that
terminology is this an invasion given
the sheer number of people crossing the
border every week every month
it really concerns me um but i put the
blame on the current administration and
the buying administration they're you
know the ones that are encouraging
people to come here to united states uh
knowing the dangers they encourage
people to go through this dangerous
journey knowing women will get raped
knowing children will be put into child
sex trafficking they know that but yet
they encourage people to come here look
uh the blame is all on the bond
administration and people like vicente
gonzalez who continue to promote people
to come here illegally knowing the
dangers look i immigrated to this yeah
but congresswoman but congressman it's
not just it's not just it's not just
you know
mothers and their three-year-old
children crossing the rio grande i mean
i've been there i've spent quite a bit
of time their cartels are running that
border they're running the border so i'm
asking you very bluntly is this an
invasion that's being run in part by the
cartels into the united states for
influence money and drugs yes or no
yeah there's definitely uh millions of
people coming into this country i do
agree with you on that and yes the
cartel has taken over the cartel you
cannot cross illegally unless you pay
thousands and thousands of dollars and
yes there's children and women coming
into our country but yet but also a lot
of horrible people terrorists also
coming into our country putting uh the
american people in danger so i agree
with you we do have a serious problem
but i do put the blame on the bind
administration
well they're letting it happen and
congresswoman again welcome to the club
you've been officially anointed and
baptized into the into the club of the
new york times hated uh great to see you
tonight thanks so much hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else